listen I got a ton of questions for you
and because I had 15 minutes I like uh
starting things off with some curveballs
oh okay go on then perhaps you
haven't been asked so uh if someone has
never seen anything that you've done
before anything you've directed uh
what's the first thing you'd like them
to watch and why well uh this is a
little highbrow and I don't think it's
going to get a lot of people running to
uh Amazon to bu it but I made a film
called eroica which is about the very
first performance of Beethoven's thirdd
Symphony which and it has the whole
Symphony played through it and it's
brilliant so check it out what is the
most nervous you've been the night
before the first day of filming and why
on the family plan because I was going
oh my God this is a big film there's a
lot of people and a lot of money writing
on this what if I screw it up okay well
you don't have to worry uh it worked out
um thanks uh if you had the financing to
make anything you want uh what would you
make and
why I've got no idea about that but I
would I would want to do something that
that goes all over the world I'd love to
see like you have a road movie but how
about a sort of you know Planes Trains
and uh space shuttle movie that goes
everywhere okay um I read that your
first job was a production runner on
1984 that's true yeah uh I have to know
what was that like uh being on the set
of that well it was amazing because I
was I forget I was a child basically and
uh you know Richard Burton was working
on it who was you know the legend the
man the Legend um and the most memorable
thing about that was when he called me
by my name I'm sure someone have told
him what what I was called but he said
hey Simon can you take this watch to the
costume department and I went well I've
landed when you were uh directing Daniel
Craig on some
voices yeah that's what it's called y
did you that did you predict that on at
the time you're like this is the next
James Bond not the next James Bond but I
thought this is the next somebody I'd
worked with him before on a on a TV show
called um our friends in the north where
he was you know he's in his 20s and he
was just
electrifying um uh yeah he was he was
always going to be something that guy
and and he he's I've still seen him and
managed to remain a total sweetheart as
well so big big props to him over the
years you've directed a lot of TV you
got to do an episode of the expanse
which is a show I absolutely love you
did Manhattan another show I loved uh
you've done C the Diplomat you've done a
lot so what is it like stepping in to
try to deliver what the producers are
looking for but also sort of do your
thing as well or is it sort of like you
have to like what's that what is it like
directing TV when they have like a
vision if you know what I mean that's a
good question I sort of I I made it
pretty much a rule that I would only
work on the first season of TV shows or
maybe the sort of premere of another
season for exactly that reason because
you know the minute you become a sort of
traffic cop or a total gun for hire it's
less rewarding on the other hand coming
from TV I love working with writers and
I I don't I'm not scared of writers
having control and being strong and
powerful um but yeah you you you've got
to make friends quickly you've got to
get get people to trust you quickly um
and as you say you want to bring
something of yourself to it rather than
just furning it in what's interesting
about this project the family plan is
that it's coming out after Arthur the
King which you shot with Mark first yes
so it's like it's one of those like wait
what so right a little bit about the
fact that like how did it sort of happen
and like you were working together on
Arthur the king and then this like how
did it work EXA exactly Arthur the king
happened you know a few couple of years
ago now we shot it um during the covid
times um and it went great we got I got
on well with Mark and you know the the
film went okay so yeah so when this came
up uh Mark was already attached to it
and and he very kindly suggested me and
uh when I read the script I thought wow
I got to take that I've got to make sure
that happens um and we're still talking
so I I'm going to get into family uh
plan and right after this question but I
I am a sucker for dog movies so talk a
little bit about Arthur the king and uh
what was it about that project that said
I need to do this Arthur the king is is
about that sort of crazy community of
people who kind of do it's adventure
racing and they sort basically do three
Iron Man races a day for a week which is
like what the um and of course you know
as Mark is Mark is a pretty pretty great
athlete we also had simu in it in it um
and what they film is is basically
they're running in this race and Mark's
character is trying to prove a point and
it's kind of the one last race before he
retires and halfway across uh this
island they come across a dog uh and
they kind of adopt it and the dog kind
of saves their lives and stuff like that
and you know so which one is the hero is
it is it Mark car or is it the dog and
of course it's both I'm G to say it's
the dog but anyway let's move let's just
move past that so with family plan uh
talk a little bit about one of the
things about this film that it does well
is it needs to have something for
everyone it's it's a family movie but it
also appeals to kids it appeals to
adults so talk a little bit about making
sure each character had a good enough
story had enough time on screen to sort
of make it that all everyone watching is
going to enjoy it I think that's really
good question um yes it's be because
it's about a family you've got to have
the all the members of the family having
equal weight you know obviously we all
know Mark Walberg and Michelle but the
the the kids are really good and you
know like a lot of families each of the
each of the characters has a kind of not
a superpower but a sort of a strength
and and I think it's really interesting
seeing what those kids are good at what
Michelle's character
uh is good at she's a former athlete so
yeah and we've we want everyone to enjoy
the film it's not like you want to give
everyone the lowest common a nominator
but one of the characters is a is a mad
gamer you know I'm not I'm not a gamer
myself I you know I play a little bit
but I don't I'm not very good but you
know that was a whole world that I
didn't know very much about but it's a
huge world as I'm sure you know and I
think a lot of our audience will they'll
be judgmental if if we get the gaming
wrong they'll be annoyed and they'll let
us know 100% um so I'm fascinated by the
editing process because it's where it
all comes together so talk a little bit
about what you learned from early
friends and family screenings or any
test screenings that impacted the
finished film uh yeah um the first cut
was very very long I I knew that and you
know but you have a as you say you have
a friends and family film and they come
in and it's a kind of a sort of kind
audience but even so you could sort of
see people like slightly yawning or
whatever so you learn about that I also
think especially in a film like this but
any film Clarity is really important for
an audience they need to understand
what's going on and if you sort of
deliberately confuse them or don't care
what they think you'll you'll slightly
lose them and they'll go okay well I
still enjoy the film but you know I I I
slightly tripped out halfway through so
it's keeping them engaged all the way
through was there a note that somebody
gave you that and when they gave it to
you you're like how did I miss this yeah
there about 20 of those I think you know
yeah but I think I think they they sort
of um they they really people people
warmed mostly to the to the family and
they actually said although we took a
lot of stuff out to make make it quicker
we put back a little bit of the family
stuff because I think people just really
enjoyed that just watching a family in a
car sing stupid songs together as long
as there's a story in there somewhere I
think people really enjoy that speaking
of singing so the one thing I expected a
number of things in this movie but the
one thing I did not expect absolutely
was seeing Mark Walberg sing
vanilla that completely came out and
left field for me because he you know
obviously used to sing and doesn't
really do it anymore so was it tough to
get him to do this whose idea was it it
was to give David kogasa the right of
credit it was his idea it was always in
the
script um and I I think Mark thought it
was funny um um I think he he enjoyed it
um because aside from his history of of
singing or rapping whatever what it also
speaks to is the sort of uh parents
embarrassing their children with their
musical choices which we all do my
children get embarrassed with my music
certainly um and I think one of my
favorite things about it's not so much
oh that's Mark wallberg rapping it's
like that's Mark wallberg playing an
annoying dad who's embarrassing his
children so I saw a picture of behind
the scenes and I make sure I I say it
right uh and like I think the working
title was Holiday Road yes this movie
was that taken from vacation and like
the the song or was this just a random
words I think it I think it was it was
random really because they you you you
pick a a title you don't necessarily
want people to know what you're filming
because you know loads of Mark warberg
fans will have read about the film
they'll all turn up and it'll all be
difficult or whatever but it was you
know as we it was it's a good title it
was a fun title I've still got the
clapperboard that says holiday roads and
I'm really happy about that I only asked
because you know Vacation National
Lampoons Vacation in the 80s they have a
very famous song by I think uh Kenny
login I could be wrong but Holiday Road
very I'm sure I'm sure there's a link I
didn't pick that title but I'm sure that
I'm sure that there's a link there you
know um so you mentioned you had longer
foot like a lot more footage did you
have like um was it a lot of deleted
scenes or was it like more like you had
an assembly cut that just had everything
and things had to go I think it's both
of that we had there was a few deleted
scenes but but it's like you know as a
director in your first cut partly you're
just wanting to see what works and
partly you don't realize that people are
going to find stuff boring you know you
go oh this is great I I can three
minutes of them singing a song in a car
fantastic and then then basically 30
seconds is plenty sure
um so one of the things is you have a
lot of action in this talk a little bit
about how you worked with your second
unit director or stunt coordinators to
pull everything off and make it all
happen well it was yeah I mean it was a
big thing for me because I hadn't done
this much action so I was kind of
obsessed of with throwing myself into it
as much as possible I really didn't want
to say hey guys go away and shoot an
action scene and bring it back to me I
wanted to be deeply involved in that but
again you know when you're making films
like this the trick is to work with good
people so I had great I had I had uh you
know sha Scott the this the sun
coordinator and the second unit director
were experienced they were very
sympathetic um you know we did some I
did some
storyboards you just go on and on and on
working out different angles and you
know having different ideas but really
it's it's something you have to plan
really carefully because you know you've
got however much money you've got It's
never enough so you have to get get that
money and not you know you can't really
spend more because people start ringing
you up and saying what's going on so you
have to sort of make the money go as far
as you can and that's the skill of it or
half the skill of it one of the things
about this is it's going to be streaming
on Apple TV um is it nice to not have to
worry about the opening weekend box
office or like what's it like you know
what I mean I think yeah I think it is
but uh I kind of excited about the Apple
thing actually cuz they are you know we
I've obviously for years and years I've
known them as a computer phone company
turns out they're a sort of hardcore
movie company you know who who knew and
then you know I think are they still the
only streamer that's won an Oscar for
best movie I want to say yes they are
yeah but don't exactly they are not 100%
they're fil they are filmmakers you know
they were they were very supportive and
they gave us a lot of leeway but they're
also filmmakers and they sort of they're
excited they're invested and they're
behind the movie so I think you know
getting this released uh in the holiday
season is is something I'm utterly
thrilled about I'm really really pleased
by that listen I'm a big fan of Apple TV
because they make some some of my
favorite TV shows are on their platform
right um one of the things that I like
is that they don't overproduce content
and I hate saying the word content but
it's not like they have 50 movies coming
out this month they very selective I
think that's the thing they they
somebody was telling me that they they
have a very curated approach to it you
know which I think is very very good so
I think as you say rather than blanket
bombing the world with with with content
I like you hate that word I think they
want to release some cool movies I think
that's their intention I have to wrap
with you but I will just say that I am
really looking forward to also seeing
Arthur the king like I said I am a
sucker for dog movies so you like it
then yeah so sometime next year sir uh
congrats I hope it's a big hit for you
thank you so much lovely to see you